[Music]
but there certainly a response that's
moving back to the notion of the nation
that's moving back to a much more walled
world there's no point in your eye just
regretting it we need to understand it
we need to understand it we need to give
people a sense of identity and belonging
where they are in the community the
neighborhood the town or city the place
they are the way in which they're
confident in their own skin in their own
heritage and background so that they can
be open and welcoming to other people
how do we well we need a I'm a great
advocate of reading George Orwell my
Tudor Bernhard Creek when I was at
university wrote a great biography of of
all well and the Civic republicanism the
patriotism that isn't narrow nationalism
that is it is inclusive not exclusive
that actually is confident enough to be
able to embrace other thoughts of their
ideas of the faiths and cultures it is
built on people being comfortable where
they are and people are deeply
uncomfortable they're resentful they're
angry and to hear them and do something
about them should have been the main
task of the Democratic Left Social
Democrats socialists whatever and we
failed them not because we didn't try in
those years and we didn't bring about
major change but firstly we we didn't
explain what we were doing in the
timescales and the narrative behind it
secondly and crucially we didn't explain
what was happening with the global
meltdown I mean it's it's just
breathtaking to find that people think
in this country that it was the
government in 2008 that was responsible
for the global meltdown but it's all
sainted but virtually half the world and
an affiliate that we were then
responsible for the that they spend
the borrowing and the investment that
was necessary to save the whole of the
economic system and had Gordon Brown not
been completely dislocated by the
allowance of scandal a year ten years
ago that coming together in April 2009
of the g20 countries and institutions
they the lead that he actually showed
which was being applauded by everybody
by Obama by the head of the IMF all of
that would have had a different
narrative to the fact that we still get
and we still got in the last week with
the departing Prime Minister that the
Labour government left a terrible legacy
of death well of course we sodding well
did because we were trying to save the
system that we should have been changing
more radically for more debates talks
and interviews subscribe today to the
Institute of Arts and ideas at AI
TV
you